with the niche I want to go into the
topic I want to go into how many other
channels are talking about this topic
how much time have you spent researching
other people that are directly talking
about what you're talking about maybe in
adjacent niches I have found
99.9% of creators have done almost zero
competitor analysis and I can hear the
objections oh comparison is the thief of
Joy I'm not saying compare yourself and
get discouraged I'm saying as a smart
strategist go look at what other options
there are out there consider the
strength of the enemy's forces because
the key that you're looking for is your
Unique Edge your unique difference and
there's always an opportunity for the
smart strategist you can always find an
angle to be a little bit different but
think about it imagine if you do not
analyze the competitors put all this
energy and effort and time into your
channel only to realize that you're
fighting an unwinable battle so you want
to ask what are the strengths and
weaknesses of my potential competitors
but you also want to ask what are my
strengths and weaknesses two things
number one I've had too much coffee
today number two if you have not seen
our free master class yet you're going
to love it if you're serious about
growing your YouTube channel just go to
think masterclass.com for a 1-hour deep
dive on demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm going to go refill
my coffee hope to see you on the class